إنه أمر جميل
ومرعب في نفس الوقت في المرة الأولى التي فعلنا فيها هذا في
المختبر ، فقد صمت الجميع ، ثم
كان هناك نوع من الضحك
العصبي وأنت تعلم لأننا كنا جميعًا كما لو كان
عليك أن تمزح معي ، وهذا
ما يحدث فقط  هذه
النفاثة النشطة للغاية من جزيئات الهباء الجوي
التي تنطلق من المرحاض
بسرعات تتراوح من متر إلى مترين في
الثانية ، لذلك إذا كانت هناك مسببات الأمراض الموجودة
في هذه الجسيمات ، فهذا يمثل
خطر التعرض للأشخاص الذين يستخدمون المرحاض
، وآمل أن يتمكن المجتمع العلمي من استخدامه
هذه المعلومات لإجراء تغييرات على
التهوية أو التطهير التي
تقلل من مخاطر التعرض بشكل عام من
المعروف أن الهباء الجوي ينقل كل من أمراض الجهاز التنفسي
والأمراض المعوية ، لذلك فإن
جميع مسببات الأمراض كوفيد ونوروفيروس
والعديد من مسببات الأمراض الأخرى يعرف الناس
أن هذه يمكن أن تكون موجودة في النفايات البشرية
وماذا  ما هو أقل فهمًا هو ما
هو خطر الانتقال الفعلي للإصابة
بالمرض من التعرض لهؤلاء
الجسيمات هناك عدد غير قليل من الدراسات
التي تعالج قضية كوفيد
وهي غير حاسمة
أنا لست مسؤولاً في الصحة العامة ولكني
أعتقد أن تقليل الوقت الذي
تقضيه في مكان مغلق حيث توجد
مراحيض تتدفق في محاولة لإخفاء القناع أثناء
قيامك بذلك.  هناك ، أعتقد أن هاتين
المقاربتين هما الإستراتيجيات الأكثر فاعلية
في هذه المرحلة ، لقد رأيت
تغريدات من جميع أنحاء العالم مع
أشخاص يقولون أشياء مثل أنا أجعل
أطفالي يشاهدون هذا الفيديو
حتى يعرفوا إغلاق الغطاء
مرحاضهم وربما يكون هناك الكثير من
القيمة في القيام بذلك